so welcome back to my kitchen it is
another day of shelter in place here in
california i really
don't know what day it is how many days
has it been
it's been a while
so one of the ways i'm trying to keep
myself busy and keep myself occupied is
by trying to make as many different
meals with the same primary ingredients
so today i'm going to show you how to
make three different dishes using the
same one can of spam
all right so the first thing i'm going
to be making is spam souby it's great as
a snack it's great as a meal it's great
to take with you not that you're going
anywhere because we're all shelter in
place so first things first i'm going to
make my rice and i have my rice right
here i just made sure to rinse it
several times until the water ran clear
to make sure all the excess starch is
out of it so i'm going to add that to
our pan add my water
cover this bring it to the boil and then
let it simmer for 10 minutes do not
remove the cover because you'll ruin
everything so now that my rice is all
cooked it's time to season it so i have
sugar salt and vinegar that i'm just
going to mix together and then microwave
until the sugar is nice and dissolved oh
god i need to clean that
i got my rice here add in my little
mixture over the top i'm just folding
this in
so my rice is done at this point i'm
just going to set it aside and get
started on my spam
so since this is my first recipe i'm
gonna open this bad boy up
beautiful cut
in half cut this guy
in half as well that'll be for my misubi
make sure that you don't throw away the
can i'm actually gonna show you a hack
on how to use this to make your musubi
and then once your musubi is cut in half
it's ready to fry so i have a non-stick
pan here that i'm going to put over
medium-high heat once it's nice and
warmed up i'm going to add my pieces of
spam i'm going to let these get nice and
golden brown which should take like two
to three minutes i'm gonna flip them do
the same exact thing on the other side
alrighty so at this point my spam looks
pretty good i'm gonna get started on my
glaze and we'll get these nice and
coated so i'm going to combine water soy
sauce and sugar together
stir this up until everything is nice
and dissolved then i'm going to add it
to my hot pan and let that kind of cook
down and form a glaze over my musubi
alrighty so now that everything is done
it's time to assemble first thing i'm
doing is i'm actually cleaning out that
used spam container that we had i'm
going to use it as a mold to help shape
my actual misubi i'm going to line the
inside with a little bit of cling film
layer in about half of my rice press
that down just to make sure it's nice
and compact add a piece of my spam on
top i'm now just going to take it out of
the can and i'm just going to repeat all
this with the second one so i'm going to
take my nori there is a shiny side and
then there is a matte side you're going
to want the shiny side down take my
musubi
place it on top fold it up and over the
top a little bit of water
we'll seal that bad boy right up
look at that that's bama soupy on to the
next thing so this next recipe is
ridiculously easy you don't even really
need a recipe instead of making a blt
i'm going to be making an slt so to
start i'm just taking one ripe tomato i
like my slices thick because i like the
tomato to be the star of the sandwich so
i'm actually going to hit them with some
salt just to soften them up a bit make
them a little bit sweeter when we bite
into it next i'm going to take another
quarter of spam and i'm just going to
slice that in half lengthwise and much
like with the misubi over medium
medium-high heat add a little bit of oil
sear off those two pieces of spam until
they're brown on both sides that'll be
about two to three minutes aside and now
that these two pieces of spam are ready
it's time to assemble our sandwich so
i'm taking two slices of toasted bread
generously add some mayonnaise to both
halves
add some lettuce add my thick slices of
tomato add my pieces of cooked spam to
the top and then just add my last piece
of bread cut in half and you're ready to
serve and that is half of our can of
spam at this point so let's move on to
our final recipe for the last half of my
spam i'm going to be making a super easy
fried rice so first things first we're
going to take our spam and we're going
to dice it now i like relatively chunky
pieces that way when you fry it they get
nice and crispy on the outside but
they're a little bit soft on the inside
i'm heating a cast iron skillet over
medium heat
adding a little bit of oil once my
skillet is at temperature add my spam
fry for about three to five minutes just
until it is all nice and golden brown
the pieces are going to shrink down just
a little bit which is totally fine
totally normal so these look great
they're nice and golden brown so i'm
just going to pull them from the pan
add my carrots
onions
and ginger gonna let these cook for a
little bit let them soften up develop
some color this is going to take about
five minutes now these guys are ready
i'm going to add my frozen peas and my
garlic
you're only going to let this go for a
minute you don't want the peas to break
down too much and you don't want the
garlic to burn this should be smelling
nice and aromatic you should smell the
garlic and the ginger in the air so the
trick to making really good fried rice
is using old rice rice that's a couple
days old that's been in the refrigerator
it's nice and dried out so i'm going to
add that
as well as my soy sauce and i'm going to
add back my cooked spam
and i'm just going to get this all
broken down nice and incorporated
and there you have it that is spam fried
rice super easy in about 15 minutes
[Music]
i don't like this
and there you have it this is three
meals all of them made with the same
single can of spam so we have our
hawaiian snack here that is the sweet
and salty spam misubi you have your slt
your spam lettuce and tomato sandwich
and finally we have my favorite your
spam fried rice with your crunchy little
pieces of spam and your crisped up rice
so i'm actually going to pack these two
up and have them at a different time
i'll probably eat them tomorrow this
will be my dinner tonight if there's any
other canned ingredients that you want
us to try that you will want to see a
few of the possibilities that you can
make with them let us know in the
comments below recipes for these are all
going to be available on tasty.com so
check them out there and until then stay
safe stay fed and i'll see you again
soon
yeah come on
[Music]
you